despite spanning more than 20 movies
over the last decade the MCU is still
going from strength to strength but with
each new Marvel movie and series the
franchise becomes that much more
difficult for newcomers to penetrate
here's what you need to know before
Marvel's phase 4 begins
despite her death in 2019 s Avengers
endgame Natasha Romanov will finally be
getting a solo film with the first major
phase for at least Black Widow but don't
expect a last-minute resurrection for
Scarlett Johansson superspy the film is
a prequel set between the events of 2016
s Captain America Civil War and Avengers
infinity war many of the plot details
for Black Widow are still under wraps
but the little has been revealed about
the heroes and villains joining Natasha
for the movie
Florence Pugh will play Yelena Bulova a
character who for a time took over the
mantle of Black Widow in Marvel Comics
David Harbor will play a character known
as the Red Guardian Russia's answer to
Captain America over a half dozen people
have been the Red Guardian in the source
material though harbor will be playing
Alexey Shostak off the first Red
Guardian to appear in the comics it
seems likely that not all of the
villains have been revealed just yet but
one of the major antagonists will be
taskmaster in the comics taskmaster is
young cunny ability to mimic just about
anything he sees someone else do no
matter how outlandish or difficult
expect an appearance from Incredible
Hulk and Civil War villain Thaddeus Ross
- unfortunately with the outbreak of
coronavirus early in 2020 the release
date of Black Widow has been delayed
which could have a significant impact on
the rest of the phase for projects but
when things finally do get into gear
Natasha swonsong will be a hell of a way
to kick things off after Black Widow the
next Marvel heroes to hit the big screen
will be the Eternals a creation of the
late great Jack Kirby based largely on
characters from kracko Roman myth the
Eternals are a powerful race of heroes
created by the godlike Celestials though
they mostly live in hiding the Eternals
protect earth specifically from the
villainous deviants kirby's eternal
series was cancelled with this 19th
issue though that happen at samson comic
book we imaginings and revivals of the
characters over the years including a
2006 2007 series by author Neil Gaiman
and artist John Romita Jr
sadly details of the film's actual story
are kind of scarce according to the
Hollywood reports
the film will include a love story
between Icarus and another eternal
Cersei and an official synopsis for the
movie has revealed that the team will be
spurred into action by a tragedy
following the events of endgame but at
this point everything else is pretty
much just speculation the first Disney
Plus MCU serious as a falcon and the
Winter Soldier which as of right now is
set to be released in August 2020
she would expect Anthony Mackie and
Sebastian Stan will be reprising their
MCU roles for this one I hate you not
much is known about the story just yet
but a few old friends and foes will be
returning in particular Daniel Bruhl
reprised his role as Helmut Zemo and
Emily VanCamp will appear as Sharon
Carter one of the more persistent rumors
about the miniseries is that despite the
elderly Steve Rogers wishes the US
government won't agree with Sam Wilson
becoming the new Captain America instead
they'll stop their own replacement John
Walker otherwise known as u.s. agent the
idea comes from an 80's comic book
storyline in which Rogers gives up his
shield and uniform and the government
gives it instead to Walker the Super
Bowl TV spots highlighting Marvel's
upcoming Disney Plus shows seemed to
support this
well those salmon Bucky obviously the
focus the trailer depicts John Walker in
a Captain America uniform waving to the
audience at some kind of big sporting
event one division is due to premiere in
2020 on Disney Plus and there's a decent
chance it'll be the weirdest thing
Marvel has ever done judging by the
Disney Plus trailer and a number of
rumors swirling around the show's
production it seems that the Android
visions return will take place in a
bizarre sitcom format the Super Bowl
spot features a few hints to hark back
to some major Marvel Comics storylines
one shot for example shows wander on a
staircase wearing a costume much more
accurate to a comic book look more
intriguingly this also a shot in which
two pacifiers pop up out of cribs in
front of the couple clearly alluding to
vision and Wonder sons Billy and Tommy
even the setting seems to call back to
the 2015-2016 vision comic by Tom King
and Gabriel Hernandez Walter which finds
the Android living in an idyllic suburb
with a family of homemade androids
it's important to remember here that
Wanda's powers in the comics and the
movies are very different so far in the
MCU wander has been portrayed as a woman
with very powerful telekinetic powers in
the comics however her abilities can
alter
itself it could be that one division is
going to bring her abilities a little
closer to the source material especially
considering this series is supposed to
tie directly into the plot of Doctor
Strange and the multiverse of madness in
February 2021
the third of Marvel's phase four films
will hit theaters shang-chi and The
Legend of the ten rings shang-chi is a
character Marvel Comics conceived in the
70s to cash in on the martial arts movie
craze but he wasn't given his powers by
straight cosmic rays or toxic waste who
are radioactive Bruce Lee instead he
fights evil with nothing but his skill
determination and the mastery of his Chi
shang-chi dropped off the radar for the
most part after the 70s but his star
began rising again in the 2010s Jonathan
Hickman brought the kung fu master
onboard for his 2013 reworking of
Avengers and more recently he has
appeared as one of the members of agents
of Atlas fans are still largely in the
dark about the plots of shang-chi some
rumors have suggested the film will be
Marvel's version of a martial arts
tournament movie along the lines of
Mortal Kombat's or bloodsport shang-chi
and The Legend of the ten rings promises
to bring to the screen a villain who's
been hinted us since 2008 Ironman in the
comics one of Iron Man's most vicious
enemies as a Mandarin an evil mastermind
who possesses ten magical rings you are
covered from an alien spaceship the
Mandarin isn't mentioned by name in Iron
Man but Raza the terrorist who captures
Tony Stark belongs to an organization
called the 10 ranks bands were fought
into thinking Ben Kingsley will be
playing the Mandarin in 2013's Iron Man
3 but instead he played dim-witted actor
Trevor Slattery it would been hired to
play the infamous terrorist by Aldrich
Killian he needed someone to take credit
for some accidental explosions at last
however the real Mandarin will be
appearing in the upcoming shang-chi film
played by Tony Leung some rumor suggests
us in the MCU the Mandarin will actually
be Shang Chi's father the idea makes
sense to in the comics shang-chi is
introduced as a son of a villain through
Manchu
but because of some IP rights issues
associated with the character there's
basically zero chance he'll be able to
appear in the upcoming movie in May 2021
Marvel Studios to release Doctor Strange
in the multiverse of madness few details
about the film are known but the title
itself suggests a Lisa
of ideas that will likely be central to
the plot when dr. strange premiered in
2016 it became the first MCU film to
confirm the narrative existed in the
multiverse in which infinite parallel
universes exist
each either a little or a whole lot
different from the MC use primal
universe it's a multiverse Yankton won
and Bruce Banner argue about an ends
game when the former worries that she
gives a time stone to banner it will
splinter her time stream into a parallel
universe that will be doomed without the
stone to protect it it's only
speculation at this point but what seems
like a big possibilities that the Doctor
Strange sequel will deal with the
fallout of either endgame or one
division both of which take place and
realities concurrent to the prime MCU
universe and with the villain nightmare
rumored to appear as well as the steady
hand of horror legend Sam Raimi behind
the camera you can expect this one to
get seriously freaky of what little is
known regarding the upcoming for love
and thunder one of the most intriguing
details is that not only will Natalie
Portman's Jane Foster return but at some
point she will become the Mighty Thor
it's unclear just how fast her will
become Thor in the movie but this did
actually happen for four years at Marvel
Comics as a result of the 2014 line wide
event original sin the original thought
loses his worthiness and hence his
ability to lift me Oh Nia at first her
identity is kept secret but eventually
it's revealed that as Jane Foster who
lifts me or Nia when Odinson can't
Foster remains as Marvel's Mighty Thor
until 2018 s Mighty Thor issue 705 when
she sacrifices her hammer in order to
defeat the destructive villain mangog
while she no longer has the ability to
summon lightning she became the new
Valkyrie after the 2018-19 event war of
the realms the 2020 super Baltus t plus
TV spots didn't show much of Loki but it
did provide one interesting detail
that's a lot of comics fans noticed
right away during the trailer Loki is
shown wearing a prisoner's uniform with
the acronym TV a written on it which
seems likely to be referencing a
somewhat obscure fictional organization
known as the time variance Authority
first appearing in 1986 is Thor issue
372 the time variant Authority seeks to
minam
any changes to the normal flow of time
through the multiverse when they're
first introduced they're represented by
the judge tread ask justice peace but in
later appearances they're shown to be a
fast comically bureaucratic organization
in 1991's Fantastic Four annual issue 24
this revealed that most of the TVA's
employees are clones bred to serve the
TVA for life and those clones are
specifically drawn to resemble Marvel
writer and editor mark Grunwald
considering this series will focus on
the version of Loki who escaped into a
parallel timeline during the events of
Avengers endgame it makes sense the TVA
would be heavily involved in his new
series what if is scheduled for the
summer of 2021 this animated series will
cover all of the films from the Infinity
Saga asking what would have happened if
things turned out differently early
hints point toward a story in which
Peggy Carter becomes Captain Britain one
in which two Chara is star-lord and even
an adaptation of Marvel Zombies a series
of comics featuring the heroes and
villains of Marvel turned into zombies
first written by Walking Dead creator
Robert Kirkman what if is named after an
actual comic series which premiered in
1977 each issue of what-if is narrated
by the mysterious figure The Watcher who
in this series will be played by West
world star Jeffrey Wright if the
animated series writers go the same
route as the comic books expect a lot of
death in this series freed from the
constraints of continuity
what if writers often take the
opportunity to kill off marquee
characters one particularly bloody
example is 1984 s1f issue 45 when a
newly transformed hulk kills the Human
Torch the thing and Iron Man only to die
himself of Thor's hands should be fun
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the MCU are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bail so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]